dans la vraie vie de veut parler dans
les bicentenaires de son sens bien ici
sont affichés 1500 noms de la paix ici
c'est mieux c'est autre chose
ils ont certainement autre chose ça nous
intéressait d'avoir un petit échange
avec toi dans le cadre marqué cours
entre jubile savoir un petit peu comment
cette api les valises en connaisse la
raison
son succès 1500 ans avec un mouton sans
activité ils ont tué 1500 temps de
présence d'enseignement de présence
spirituelle
comment est ce que toi ton point de vue
d'actifs actuellement tu cliques secret
moi je crois que déjà 1500 c'est d'abord
un événement
j'ai pas besoin de rédiger plus le temps
le martyre de cette fameuse légion
thébaine un événement qui a marqué ce
lieu c'est en ce lieu bien sûr toute une
histoire qui s'est enchaîné
autour de ce vieux c'est à dire que en
un recul là la valeur témoignage
fondamental témoignages qui je pense a
résonné au travail tous les âges si je
prends juste un exemple si sa mue en
france parce que il avait décidé que
samedi serait comme patron des
chevaliers et on sait aussi ce top 100
lycées et universités dans différents
grands restaurants on sait aussi le lieu
est de passage du strict et je pense que
la stabilité est un temps fort je crois
et je suis pas valaisan d'objets mais
j'ai quand même beaucoup d'affection
pense quand on sait qu'à 30 ans je suis
là donc je colle oser dire que l'abbaye
sa force
mais quand même sa force c'est de ne pas
être que dans les alpes je pense que ce
qui est essentiel c'est que cette abbaye
a toujours trouvé des forces vives mais
pas seulement dans les hommes mais un
intérêt transnationales et non pas d'un
lieu mais à l'intérêt qui lui donne une
vocation universelle être sa 206 est si
c'est un terme à jerry yang devant
lesquels c'est une somme de concours de
circonstances et la probabilité mais je
retiens tu de ta réponse importante de
ce message constant depuis 1500 ans
fonds sont ravis de ça dans le monde
virtuel insultes app stores hic est
autorisé lundi vague du musée oui dans
le vestiaire je crois que le message
qu'une tonne ses martyrs ne meurent
j'aime bien en parler c'est que c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
actuelle aujourd'hui il y a des choses
il ya des situations pas ce qu'est qu'on
doit dire non et je pense que ça n'est
pas seulement le fait seul peut
seulement les chrétiens c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus vaste et c'est
quelque chose qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui encore on a des gens qui ont
le courage de dire non au prix même de
l'heure alors je leur ai personnellement
j'ai toujours été fasciné par ce lieu
passe du mieux et ces mecs arômes l'idée
d'entrer dans la communauté du chemin
c'est un abîme saint maurice au pied du
mur là même où a eu lieu le le martyre
de cette jeune et belle que je suis
entré après évidemment les modalités
d'existence d'une communauté sont liées
aussi alors une question déjà cationorm
sens pour la formation astral qui se
traduit dans les paroisses dans un
collège sollicités même si longue
tradition des d'écoles sociale
enfin le collège moderne
106 mais moi j'ai été voulu par lazzari
ça pour donner et permettre aussi de
transformer implique pour ça que déjà
bien avant mais avait saint maurice sur
l'histoire est intrinsèquement d'hier 7g
dct il vous faisait croire d'économies
sont habitués aux belges encore quelques
enseignements activités à l'internât si
tu devais faire un parallèle cette
pérennité ses 1500 ans et la vie d'une
entreprise en entreprise grande
tradition en suisse quelque on pourrait
tirer comme leçons du succès ouais mais
dans la je vais dire des choses et puis
a travaillé j'y suis un petit peu
orienté mais la lame ne serait possible
bonjour les amis tant pis mais quand le
pianiste
on a entendu à certains villages non je
veux dire par là c'est si vous regardez
notre service
je regardais le pedigree le csv défi
cible c'est aux critères actuels sur la
demande du catch est temps de crise il a
misé ci n'est pas pareil entrée libre
en plus celui qui la vit à l'appel de
son équipière là ne même pas eu le
courage d'aller jusqu'au bout il l'a
remis par trois fois mais simplement ce
qu'il a fait je crois la cette force est
la 7e et ils ont bien mal fou et
beaucoup temps à comprendre là le plus
de l'entreprise puisque jusqu'à presque
l'avant veille il y est complètement la
façon dont cette année et autant il le
rappeler est mille fois et je crois que
ce qui fait le quotidien extraordinaire
c'est que justement on ne choisit pas le
personnel c'est à dire que on peut bien
sûr à la france corps
à tant de choses beckham l'initiative
vient de d'ailleurs voilà des mots qui a
trop agressif
l'assemblée qui peut-être mais pas tout
de même tonalité gidienne propose
d'ailleurs de plus haut comme vous
voulez mais après ben c'est aussi une
façon de se mirent en est on est dans ma
quelque chose une histoire qui nous
dépasse et je me souviens des ces
paroles que me disaient non à la biais
renvoi ils avaient m'avait dit peu
importe le métier comme frappeur
préparait déjà que j'allais rentrer et à
choisir ce qu'ils en pensent et non pas
le métier qui fait que diffraction
l'activité
c'est l'état que j'ai envie le fait
d'être religieux donné et je crois le
plus sympa que j'y crois parce que si
j'avais été le cas les professionnels
quand tu m'a convoqué pour venir d'haïti
montrer les vidéos des prestations
bah je serai pas que je serais parti à
tous les genres je suis finalement on
peut venir même au risque de l'offre est
toujours en fout ça prendra seul pas
seulement
je me souviens que j'ai signé un papier
je salue le montant gagné générations
d'élèves explique la spiritualité à sa
place dans une entreprise aujourd'hui tu
penses est ce que toi tu es des fois
dans ta pratique ont contacté les autres
glisse avec des chants qui travaillent
dans des entreprises avec les
entraîneurs pas où ils fatalement je
pense qu'une entreprise qui n'a pas de
spiritualité c'est l'impossible pour moi
le jeu permettrait base qu'est ce que
c'est que la spiritualité
je pense qu'on est tous spirituelle sans
être forcément à connotation chrétienne
ou dix autres c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
n'a pas cette dimension là quelqu'un qui
était incapable de se mettre au diapason
du monde et des autres mais aussi d'une
part de transcendance et je crois que
dans un position de l'entreprise
il faut aussi avoir une part quelque
chose qui nous amène plus haut et pas
seulement inscrits revient sur les
chiffres parce que si on y réfléchit ça
ou si on n'ose pas poser pour avoir
aussi une dose de confiance alors on
appelait ça la fois où on appelle ça
passe à la fois je ne sais pas mais
j'étais impressionné par vannes quand on
nous a parlé là de philips ou des deux
collègues kodak 80 d'entre eux ils n'ont
pas osé
oui son public et rigoureux et il ya des
moments quand on quand on aime ça parce
que je retiens de tout ça et les belles
inventions et les belles idées
il ya un moment donné c'est comme désiré
ce qu'on va jouer tous le rouge
ou bien se voir et je crois que là il ya
elle parle de courage qui fait que l'on
n'ose et je pense que dans cette façon
dans cette audace je vois tous les gens
qui sont puissamment engagés dans des
choses exceptionnelles le clic en gage
la vie ou qui engage hoffman sa propre
survie comme la montagne ou autre je me
rends compte que même si on parle de
dieu emmené dans une notion même de 30
heures de 2 311
tout part et d'autre part dans cette
interview du travail spécifique à
l'intérieur c'est une tradition de la
vie de saint maurice d'abord des gens
des jeunes
contat hickel collège beaucoup de jeunes
qui passent à l'intimité et d'abord
cette diversité de parcours centimes ce
que tous les gens c'est un élément
essentiel au fond on se travaille
toujours du lourd bon alors c'est que ça
fait maintenant la 26e année que je fais
internationaux je vienne à la table dans
la salle
il a profité de ce que j'avais droit de
place témoigne alain perreault
mais je veux dire que on reçoit beaucoup
de jeunechamp
je pense que le recrutement de
l'internât d'aujourd'hui n'est pas le
même que celui d'autrefois en venait à
l'internât du collège saint maurice
parce que c'est peut-être un collège
public c'est à dire pour venir parce que
c'était un rallye mais maintenant on
vient parce que c'était un internat
parce qu'il ya quand même une histoire
parce que aussi le collège 102 mais
aussi parce qu'il ya c'est un lieu aussi
où les jeunes redécouvrent finalement
quelque part quelque chose pour les
reconstruire
je le dis parce que ça les voir de loin
pas que de moi mais je pense que c'est
aussi une manière de poser un regard sur
des jeunes qui se limite pas à ce qui
pour en produire dans l'immédiateté
je crois qu'il faut avoir quand on
regarde quelqu'un les yeux un petit peu
l'avenir c'est à dire qu'on a des jeunes
pour lequel on donnera cet arc baic va
finalement si l'on croit et si on entre
ici on seat
je pense que ce qu'on pourrait trouver
trouver comme le sont peut-être de son
bien vite et on a trouvé sa gueule il
faut avoir le courage d'engager
quelqu'un dans lequel d'être on n'aurait
pas tout miser qu'ils n'en viennent pas
forcément les diplômes mais on doit
aussi apprendre ça je passe tous les
rageux monde entier
il faut avoir des yeux pour voir et pas
seulement les yeux rivés sur papier ou
diplômes parce que on a retrouvé les
jambes car moi je vois que c'est 0000 je
prends
c'est la conséquence du chrono est ce
que tu es satisfait sur mokhtar et
l'entretien courage et transcendante
je trouve ça bien plus de montfort les
discussions s'étaient c'est ce que
véhicule et les marques